bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux logos
[Musique]
on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la
première vidéo de ma série la sociologie
en mouvement si vous avez raté la vidéo
d'annonce de cette série je vous laisse
aller la regarder et sinon eh bien c'est
parti pour ce premier épisode alors pour
ce premier épisode nous allons parler du
ml dans un premier temps je vais revenir
sur les faits qu est ce que le m élèves
comment il a été créé quelles actions
ont été menées puis dans un second temps
je vous expliquerai dans quelle mesure
le mlf est devenu un lieu de production
des savoirs et dans une première partie
nous interrogeons ensemble les regards
académique qui ont été posées sur le mlf
alors nous allons commencer avec les
faits le mlf c'est donc le mouvement de
libération des femmes qui donc a eu lieu
en france ces immobilisations qui a pour
date de commencement une date assez
précise si elle a été controversée c'est
la date du 26 août 1970 alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé le 26 oct alors le 26
août 9 militante féministe issus de
divers petits groupes d'action se
retrouvent pour mener une action choc en
fait elles partagent toutes les 9 la
volonté de mener une action
spectaculaire en solidarité avec les
féministes étasunienne qui font grève ce
jour-là elle se retrouve donc toutes les
9 devant l'arc de triomphe et tente de
déposer une gerbe de fleurs en hommage à
plus inconnu que le soldat reconnu sa
femme elles ont donc les gerbes dans les
bras elle s'avance mais sont interrompus
par des policiers qui les emmènent de
manière assez brutale dans une des
jambes de l'arc de triomphe où il se
trouve en commissariat elles sont donc
arrêtés et les images de cette action
déjà la symbolique puis les images qui
en ont des prises et il faut que ça se
déroule en plein mois d'août et qui a
pas grand chose à se mettre sous la dent
pour la presse font que cette action les
médiatiser plusieurs journaux en font
leur une comme le ror et la presse
évoque d'elle-même des militantes du
mouvement de libération de la femme même
parfois le mouvement de libération de la
femme française et c'est donc ainsi que
le mouvement de libération des femmes
aînées les neuf militante qui sont donc
à l'origine de cette action font en fait
partie de groupes qui se rassemblent
autour de cette nouvelle entité qu'est
le mlf les militantes du mlf lance une
formule choc les ration des femmes année
zéro qui va être prise comme de très
nombreux médias alors qu'est ce qui se
passe pendant sept années 70 et plus
largement au cours des débuts des années
70 en france le mlf s'impose tout
simplement comme un mouvement social clé
dans l'organisation politique des années
70 leur première action choc en tant que
militante du mlf se tient au cours des
états généraux de la femme elle le
magazine elle organise donc les états
généraux de la femme qui doivent
rassembler des entreprises des
journalistes politiques etc sur de
nombreux sujets qui concernent donc la
femme et les militantes jam élèves
organisent plusieurs actions d'abord il
y à un questionnaire qui circulent donc
elle retourne ce questionnaire pour le
rendre ironique et montrer tout le
sexisme du kali les emprunts et ensuite
plusieurs militantes féministes parmi
lesquelles christine delphy réussissent
à entrer aux états généraux de la femme
et obtiennent 5 minutes de discours
christina fille prend la parole juste
après le ministre du travail elle a cinq
minutes et elle commence en discours en
déplorant le fait qu après plus d'un an
de travail effectué essentiellement par
des femmes pour l'organisation de ces
états généraux on donne finalement la
parole à des hommes elle est applaudi
par l'assemblée et cela contribue à
faire du mlf un mouvement plus populaire
puisque ces discours va sortir des
simples sphère militante et toucher
d'autres types de femmes en parallèle
d'autres événements vont contribuer à la
popularisation du mlf en tant que
mouvement social par exemple l'écriture
de l'hymne des femmes ou l'hymne du mlf
y est décrit sur l'air du chant des
marais en 1971 et qui est toujours
aujourd'hui chanter dans les
manifestations féministes lama né en
1971 le mlf commence à éditer sa propre
publication le torchon brûle qui est
vendu dans la rue et puis un autre
événement qui va contribuer à imposer le
mlf en tant que mouvement social
incontournable des années 70 c'est le
manifeste des 343 alors le manifeste des
343 vous en avez sûrement déjà entendu
parler c'est un manifeste pro avortement
qui a été publié dans le nouvel
observateur rapidement surnommé le
manifeste des 343 [ __ ] par charlie
hebdo le manifeste est en fait signé par
343 fans donc de célébrités pour
l'essentiel qui reconnaissent avoir eu
recours à l'avortement qui était alors
illégal en france elle risque dans toute
la prison mais utilisent leur célébrité
au service de la cause à la suite du
manifeste des 343 les manifestations pro
avortement deviennent de plus en plus
importantes sont les premières à se
réaliser de manière publique en france
alors que l'avortement est toujours
illégal est lourdement pénalisé
d'autres combats suivront celui pour
l'avortement le mlf ou du moins une
partie du mlf va se mobiliser pour la
reconnaissance et la pénalisation du
viol et également pour l'accès libre et
gratuit à la contraception
alors voilà pour un rapide aperçu de ce
qu'a été le mlf en tant que mouvement
social que mobilisation publique en
france pour la libération des femmes
mais comme je vous l'avais expliqué dans
les vidéos de la sociologie en mouvement
mon but c'est aussi de vous expliquer
comment les mouvements sociaux ont
interagi avec l'université autant comme
lieu de production des savoirs que comme
objet du savoir et commencer par le mlf
c'est pas anodin parce que le mlf c'est
un cas assez particulier en tant que
mobilisation sociale en effet le mlf a
agi comme un véritable laboratoire
d'idées sur les questions de la
libération des femmes le mlf a été un
mouvement assez soudain dans son ampleur
puisque on avait d'abord plusieurs
petits groupes qui avaient des idées
parfois même contradictoires qui s'est
retrouvée d'un coup à devoir se
structurer en tant que mouvement plus
global donc le fait de passer de petits
groupes à un mouvement plus large a
poussé les militantes féministes à
devoir s'organiser et trouver des lignes
directrices des points de rencontre
entre toutes ces sous branches du
féminisme les féministes raconte souvent
qu'un ennemi plutôt inattendu a fait son
apparition alors qu'on pourrait
s'attendre à ce que les féministes se
tirent la bourre entre elles du fait de
ne pas trouver forcément de terrain
d'entente sur leur destination de ce que
doit être la libération des femmes ou
des actions qu'il faut mener pour
contribuer à la libération des femmes
l'ennemi ou du moins le principal
obstacle qu'elle vous rencontrer ça va
être plutôt des hommes qui sont
militants de gauche en effet le mlf
décide de tenir toutes ces réunions en
non mixité c'est à dire uniquement entre
femmes et ce quelque chose qui va
fortement déplaire à leurs camarades
masculins de gauche puisqu'ils veulent
eux aussi parce passion - et surtout il
y a un grand sujet qui parcourt encore
les mouvements de gauche à l'heure
actuelle c'est la question de la
primauté de la lutte des classes selon
les minutes en masculin la lutte des
classes entre prolétaires et bourgeois
devrait être la priorité de tous les
prolétaires pour aboutir à ce que marx a
théorisé en tant que révolution
prolétarienne pour autant l'argument mis
en avant par plusieurs féministes du mlf
c'est de dire que jusqu'à présent aucun
mouvement aucun parti dirigé par des
hommes nami à son agenda la libération
des femmes et en a fait une priorité
ainsi une partie des militantes du mlf
reprend une phrase qu'on attribue à la
féministe flora tristan qui devrait
prononcer en 1830 à savoir que la femme
et la prolétaire de l'homme on voit bien
que le mlf a donc été dès ses débuts un
mouvement qui a agi comme un laboratoire
d'idées notamment pour la gauche en
effet les sciences sociales et à leur
traversée par les théories marxistes et
le mlf a contribué à fournir une
première approche critique des théories
marxistes une autre spécificité du mlf
c'est que de grandes académicienne sont
issus du mouvement sont en fait
d'anciennes militantes ses militantes
académicienne ont contribué à la
théorisation du mlf en tant que
mobilisation sociale de lutte pour la
libération des femmes pour autant ces
universitaires bien qu étant issus du
même mouvement féministe non pas du tout
développés leur portée de la même
manière j'ai donc décidé dans cette
vidéo de vous présenter trois figures
intellectuelles majeur ici du mlf pour
vous montrer les divergences qui ont
existé au sein du mlf et aussi pour vous
montrer comment différentes
épistémologie peuvent survenir à partir
d'un même mouvement social alors la
première que je vais évoquer c'est
christine delphy christine delphy est
une sociologue théoricienne du féminisme
matérialiste qui a été la première à
penser le travail domestique en tant que
mode de production à part entière alors
je m'explique dans l'ami principal qui
est son ouvrage majeur s inscrit dans la
continuité de la pensée marxiste mais en
montre les limites elle revient
notamment sur un grand impensé de la
pensée marxiste qui est le travail
domestique fournis par les femmes à nice
donc ce type de travail comme étant un
mode de production à part entière qu'il
n'est pas le mode de production
capitaliste mais bien un mode de
production patriarcale elle théorise
donc l'assignation systématique des
femmes à un travail gratuit et explique
que ce travail fait des femmes une
classe à part c'est à partir de laquelle
pose la question de savoir qui est
propriétaire du mode de production
patriarcale du mode de production
domestique et active bénéficie le
travail gratuit fourni par les femmes
elles démontrent donc comment
l'oppression des femmes est érigée en
mode de pro action dans un système
patriarcal la seconde universitaire que
je vais vous présenter aujourd'hui c'est
monique wittig monique wittig est une
écrivaine et une thérapie sienne
féministes qui est la première à
souligner l'importance du lesbianisme
dans le mouvement de libération des
femmes selon elle le fait même d'être
lesbienne et une position radicale qui
exclut de fait les femmes des rapports
sociaux de sexe c'est dans ce sens
qu'elles formulent une idée choc celle
que les lesbiennes ne sont pas des
femmes ce qu'elle veut dire par là c'est
que ce qui définit les femmes ce sont
leurs rapports aux hommes et notamment
le rapport de domination entre en
méforme et donc en tant que lesbienne on
n'échappe à ces rapports sociaux de sexe
et donc à ces rapports de domination
entre hommes et femmes monique wittig
bien qu'étant une des membres
fondatrices du mlf puisque présente à
l'action du 26 août 1970 alain de trion
et peu à peu marginalisé en fait il ya
de nombreuses militantes féministes qui
ne souhaitent pas que le m relève soit
réduit à la question du lesbianisme et
donc monique wittig est invité à ne pas
mettre en avant ses idées peu à peu elle
se lasse de tout ça décide de partir vit
aux etats-unis avec sa compagne la
bassée idées sont bien mieux accueillie
notamment du fait de la montée en
puissance des théories queer c'est
d'ailleurs aux états unis que monique
wittig publie son ouvrage théorique
majeur la pensée straight qui ne sera
traduit et publié en français que de
nombreuses années après money visites
ont d'ailleurs un peu dans l'oubli en
france et c'est en fait avec trouble
dans le genre de job dit butler qu'elle
revient sur le devant de la scène du
point de vue théorique elle est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de nouveaux
enseigné notamment dans les formations
en études féministes alors la troisième
et dernière universitaires issus du mlf
que je vais vous présenter c'est
antoinette fouque antoinette fouque
c'est une psychanalyste féministes qui
au sein du mlf a créé la tendance
psychédélique
analyse et politique latente psycho ou
permettait à des militantes du mlf de se
retrouver autour de questions de
psychanalyse et notamment de commenter
au rize et la libération des femmes au
sein de la psychanalyse antoine flück
s'inscrit dans l'héritage lacanien et
cherche à développer une théorie qui
viendrait combler un impensé de la
psychanalyse à savoir la sexualité
féminine d'ailleurs si vous est
familière et familier de l'hymne des
femmes vous avez sûrement en tête ce
passage où on évoque les femmes en tant
que continent noir c'est en fait une
référence affreuse qui utilisé
l'expression continent noir pour évoquer
la vie sexuée de la femme adulte qui ne
parvenait pas à expliquer ankama
psychanalytique est donc en train est
faux que va chercher à théoriser la vie
sexuelle féminine et crée donc le
concept de libido créant dis donc la
libido créatrice par opposition à la
libido falic qui serait le propre des
hommes donc selon en est fou que le fait
que les femmes bénéficient de la
compétence biologique qu'est la
gestation permettrait aux femmes
d'accéder à cette libido créant 17e dit
rask a décrit comme un mouvement
incessant une énergie un désir qui
serait selon elle les lans infini du
vivant alors vous l'aurez compris cette
pensée qui est pourtant très en vogue us
à 70 du fait du développement de la
psychanalyse créé de vives tensions au
sein du mlf notamment avec les
lesbiennes et aussi avec toutes les
militantes qui refuse d'avoir des
enfants ou qui refusent d'être réduite à
leurs capacités reproductrices car tout
simplement elle revendique une sexualité
qui n'a pas pour but la procréation
brève on a très vite une scission au
sein du mlf entre les piquets peau et
celle qu'on appelle les beauvoirienne
pour résumer les pieds peu honte un
discours qui s'appuie sur les
particularités biologiques des corps
féminin tandis que les beauvoirienne
affirme que si les corps féminins et
masculins présente des différences
biologiques tout ce qui relève des
pratiques sociales et dont la sexualité
fait partie des pans de socialisation
féminine et masculine différencier voilà
donc pour christine delphy monique
wittig et antoinette fouque en très bref
il y aurait encore beaucoup à dire sur
ces théories sienne mais aussi sur
d'autres théoricienne issu du mouvement
de libération des femmes j'espère que ce
rapide aperçu vous aura permis
d'appréhender des grandes tendances
scientifique épistémologique et
d'observer en fait les différences
fondamentales de théorisation en
fonction des disciplines et cela même
alors que ces chercheuses sont issus du
même mouvement social dans la troisième
partie de cette vidéo je vais avez vous
interrogez les regards académique qui
ont été portées sur le mlf je vous ai
d'avoir présenté donc des chercheuses
qui sont issus du mls des théoriciennes
issus du mlf et je voudrais également
présenter un cas particulier celui de
françoise picq france aspic c'est une
ancienne militante du mlf qui est
aujourd'hui chercheuse et qui se définit
elle-même comme chercheuse famille ayant
pris pour objet d'étude le mouvement
féministe qui le mlf on a donc avec
france explique le glissement de la
position militante à la position
universitaire c'est une première car ça
va tout simplement impensable que des
militantes deviennent universitaire et
prennent le mouvement paul auquel ils
ont milité en tant qu objet d'étude on
les aurait accusé d'être trop subjective
par exemple aujourd'hui c'est une
tendance qui est bien plus acceptée dans
le milieu universitaire avec évidemment
une quête de l'objectif ication
scientifique donc france au spi a
participé à la formation d'une nouvelle
positionne alité scientifique qui est
aujourd'hui très pratiqué dans les
recherches en sciences sociales alors
france aspic elle a publié un ouvrage
qui s'intitule libération des femmes les
années mouvement qui a été publié pour
la première fois en 1993 réédité en 2011
cet ouvrage c'est tout simplement une
référence sur le mouvement féministe des
années 70 une référence puisque c'est le
seul ouvrage exhaustif au sujet du mlf
en effet comment vous parler de la façon
dont l'université a traité le mlf sans
vous dire que concrètement le mlf est un
grand oublié de l'université la
sociologue olhanense on explique que le
mouvement féministe a longtemps été
ignorée par la sociologie des mouvements
sociaux parce qu'il a été tout
simplement pas considéré comme un
mouvement social au même titre par
exemple que le mouvement ouvrier on a
donc une absence significative de
travaux scientifiques commencent à être
rattrapé avec quelques travaux qui
notamment comparé le mlf à des
mouvements féministes contemporain mais
qui se livre assez souvent au jeu des 7
différences on a quelques articles donc
à ce sujet il ya également une thèse qui
a été soutenue en 2014 mais keane thèse
de littérature sur les écrivaines et les
collectifs éditoriaux issus du mlf et
donc au final l'essentiel de la
littérature scientifique sur le mlf a
été produite par d'anciennes militantes
on a donc ici la preuve par l'exemple
que si les subalternes ici les femmes ne
développe pas d épistémologie propre et
bien les sciences sociales restent
enfermés dans les rapports de domination
qu'elles entendent montrer déconstruire
et analyser la production de savoirs
continue donc d'être biaisé dans le cas
de l'étude sociologique du mouvement
social qu'est le mouvement de libération
des femmes l'absence d' analyse
conséquente révèle un biais important
qui est le biais androcentrique landreau
sentry c'est un billet qui été théorisée
par l'anthropologue nicole mathieu dans
l'anatomie politique et qui repose sur
l'hégémonie du regard scientifique
masculin sur les faits sociaux donc le
fait que le mlf n'est pas été considéré
comme un mouvement social digne d'être
analysées scientifiquement
ça nous montre bien que landreau centre
y est encore très présente dans les
sciences sociales je profite donc de
cette vidéo pour lancer un appel aux
jeunes chercheurs et chercheuses qui
seraient intéressés par la sociologie
des mouvements sociaux il ya plein de
choses à dire sur le mouvement de
libération des femmes tant du point de
vue de l'héritage militants que des
modes d'action et j'en passe voilà je
m'arrêter ici pour ce premier épisode de
la série la sociologie en mouvement
j'espère que ça vous aura permis de
découvrir un peu plus ce qu'était le mlf
et notamment comment le mlf a interagi
avec l'université si cette vidéo vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la
chaîne mais également à la cassette
vidéo à la partager et à faire vivre
sociaux logos je vous retrouverai pour
une nouvelle vidéo et je vous dis à
bientôt sur sociaux de beauce
[Musique]